the israeli military on a dawn raid in
the occupied west bank they arrived in
force in the city of nablus
looking for this man ibrahim al-nabusi a
senior figure in al-aqsa mata's brigades
israel had tried to capture him before
and he got away this time they succeeded
trapping him in this building in the old
city
these bullet holes a testament to a
firefight that continued through the
early morning
this man says he found the bullseye
when i arrived we saw smoke and fire
we used our t-shirts to cover our noses
and entered the house we found a body
right here a guy recognized him and said
it was ibrahim
israeli forces also killed two other
members of the group and dozens of
people were injured in the fighting in
the crowded old town
thousands accompanied the funeral
procession from these scenes you can see
how popular ibrahim al-naboosey was in
the town of nablus for these people he
was a resistance fighter for israeli
authorities he was a terrorist who shot
at soldiers and civilians a threat that
they had to remove
we asked nida salawan a teacher also on
the march what she thought
when a young man opens his eyes to life
and sees killings terrorism violations
of people's rights and attacks on houses
then it's his right to defend his
legitimate rights and to defend his
homeland
the israeli raid came just four days
after it targeted another armed group
the palestinian islamic jihad in gaza
now more deaths including on tuesday
afternoon a 17 year old teenager killed
by israeli forces during protests in
hebron
and all across the occupied west bank
businesses shut and a general strike in
place john holman al jazeera nablus
occupied west bank
let's take a closer look at the
palestinian resistance movement in the
occupied territories alexa brigades is
an armed group that emerged during the
second intifada it's splintered from
fatah and at times operate alongside
islamic jihad in nablus and janine there
are numerous palestinian groups that are
resisting israel's illegal occupation
the palestinian liberation organization
known as the plo was formed in the 60s
and operates as an umbrella group of
several political factions
it excludes groups such as hamas and
islamic jihad in gaza who have opposed
all forms of negotiations with israel
hamas is amateur had the al-aqsa mata's
brigades among others cooperates
militarily and agree that armed
resistance to the occupation is the only
way to end it and to achieve palestinian
self-determination
is the spokesman for the fatah movement
and a member of the fatah revolutionary
council he says israel is motivated by
its upcoming election
we see the closer we get to the israeli
elections the bloodier the israeli
attacks get on the palestinians it is
because the israeli government is trying
to compete with its predecessors trying
to appear more violent against
palestinians hoping to gain more ground
in the israeli elections so they in
israel there is this thought which is
well established the more violent you
are towards the palestinian the closer
you get to winning elections it appears
that israel is coming closer to an
all-out war against the palestinian this
whole thing started in jerusalem when
the israeli government allowed the
israeli settlers to storm the al-aqsa
mosque and change the the the status quo
of the mosque then it spread to janine
it went to jeanine where the israelis
continued to to arrest more palestinian
individuals then we saw the assault on
gaza and now it has come to nablus
israel knows all too well that such
targeted killings will result result in
a reaction of the same type on the
palestinian on the palestinian side
israel is trying to destroy all the
efforts of the palestinian government be
it engineer or nablus you have the
palestinian authority trying to
establish the rule of law trying to
maintain stability and calm that is on
the one hand and on the other hand you
have the heavy arm the heavy hand of the
israeli army trying to work against the
palestinian efforts because they do not
want palestinian president obama to
succeed
in doing what he wants to do he wants to
qualify palestine to become a democratic
state an independent state and that is
exactly what the israeli governments do
not want to see